world leaders including U.S President
Joe Biden have begun to arrive in London
ahead of Queen Elizabeth's funeral on
Monday thousands of mourners have been
queuing in central London for a fourth
straight day hoping to see the coffin of
the late monarch
let's continue to patiently wait in a
kilometers long queue for a chance to
Glimpse the coffin of Queen Elizabeth II
as she lies in state at parliament's
Westminster Hall in central London some
mourners were treated to an unscheduled
Walkabout by King Charles and his son
William who came out to thank those who
have been queuing overnight for several
hours
just meeting the king himself and the
prince as just my whole work work
[Music]
foreign
on Saturday William joined his brother
Harry and their cousins to stand vigil
by their grandmother's coffin Prince
Harry who is no longer working Royal was
allowed to wear a military uniform at
the King's request like their parents
the day before the eight cousins stood
vigil for 15 minutes as mourners
continued to quietly file by
can't describe it it was just
right nothing obviously ever experienced
before and yeah it was just so poignant
so emotional and we were very lucky
enough to see all the grandchildren
there as well so
um but yeah a real Moment In Time
King Charles III is meeting with
Commonwealth leaders at Buckingham
Palace this is a delicate time for the
56-member body with some questioning the
Commonwealth's purpose last year
Barbados became the world's newest
Republic after it officially removed the
queen as its head of state Charles will
be counting on his whole family to keep
the Commonwealth Family of Nations
intact
more heads of state including U.S
President Joe Biden are arriving in time
for Queen Elizabeth's State funeral on
Monday more than ten thousand police
officers are being deployed making it
the largest Security operation in
London's history
for more we are now joined by our
correspondent Brigitte Moss who's
reporting from London well the final day
of the queens of lying in stateburg and
although I suspect I know the answer to
this question let me ask you have the
queue subsided
well it's not annual Q it's the queue
and there's even a queue for queuing for
the queue and no it hasn't subsided um
the official advice is there is a
Twitter handle for it and there is a
YouTube channel for it and the official
advice is from the ministry of culture
don't set off now to basically join the
queue because the queue is already very
very long and the queue to join the
queue is also very long so people you
know still want to be part of this
momentous event and this I suspect is
why many people are still thinking about
going but it's really very very very
busy it's of course an extremely British
Affair I've been there I've spoken to
people at the queue and they were very
happy
um that they were there you know made
friendships exchange phone numbers to
share their memories afterwards but at
the moment they're being advised if they
are not already on their way or actually
in the queue not to set off and join
my goodness a cue to join the queue um
what's planned for today
well at the moment we still have heads
of States arriving we've seen that
President Biden has arrived for example
in London and we know that King Charles
is going to be very very busy today in
Buckingham Palace he's meeting prime
minister Liz truss but also
importantly he's meeting the prime
ministers of the so-called Realms where
the where he is still the head of state
and we're informed that this includes
Papua New Guinea and Antigua and Barbuda
also he's meeting other heads of state
of commonwealth countries and you've
already hinted at it you know it will be
very very important for him to keep
these connections with the leaders of of
commonwealth countries in order to make
sure that this organization will go
forward under his leadership
clearly a very emotional time for many
britons how is the country gearing up
for tomorrow's funeral
to London so it's incredibly busy in
London and we're expecting more people
to come so people have been camping
overnight near Buckingham Palace they
want to get basically front seats at the
processions tomorrow and they want to be
there and see it with their own eyes and
not just on one of these many many
screens and security forces are in
basically an overdrive they police are
coming from all across the country to
make sure that there's huge Security
operation is going well at this massive
event on Monday in London all lives will
be upon it I am sure very good Maas
reporting from London many thanks